[Musique]
e
oui
aujourd'hui la vengeance du bateau
fantôme
c'était autrefois et il ya bien
longtemps
le marin battaient la semelle sur les
quais de l'un ou l'autre de ces ports où
il fait si bon s'abriter quand là que le
gros vent du large
du côté de cherbourg de saint malo
peut-être on sait plus lequel mais
qu'importe on dit qu'il s'appelait le
gaz qu'il ne croyait ni aux
superstitions ni aux légendes et qu'il
partie un jour sur la mer il avait tant
et tant rêvé d'embarquer à bord d'un de
ses grands voiliers qui pavoisaient dans
le port des navires superbe film engrais
coiffé d'une chevelure de voiles
blanches et la marie gabrielle avait
bien voulu de lui les vieux marin ceux
qui n'ont plus besoin de quitter le
havre pour faire d'infini voyage lui
avais pourtant dit en tirant sur leur
pipe que la marie gabrielle ce n'était
pas le vrai nom de cette goélette qu'en
d'autres temps on l'appelait la
trépident les gens se pressaient sur les
quais pour l'avoir cingler vers la haute
mer
les matelots se disputaient pour monter
à son bord et quand elle rentrait au
port
quelles animations on s'embrassait on se
racontait les dernières nouvelles dans
un déluge de coiffe blanche et de
bonnets et puis pour quelques sous de
plus ou pour quelque autre réseau qu'il
saura jamais l'équipage s'étaient
mutinés et s'étaient dispersés en
arrivant au port on avait désigné un
autre capitaine mais il était devenu fou
quelques semaines plus tard un autre
avait péri en mer quant au troisième on
l'avait retrouvé mort au pied du mât de
misaine alors nul n'avait jamais plus
voulu prendre la mer sur l'intrépide on
avait vendu la galette et on lui avait
donné un autre
non tout ça ça n'est rien de bon quand
on change le nom d'un navire ça n'est
rien de bon ça porte malheur et et le
gall n'allait pas écouté ses ras de
terre
l'idée de partir de naviguer il avait
toujours eu bien ancré dans sa tête
et lorsque la marie gabrielle s'était
élancé poussé par un bon vent le gall
avait oublié toutes ces sornettes avant
même que la côte est disparu à l'horizon
et puis un jour mais c'était peut-être
la nuit et si c'était la nuit elle était
venue de bonheur on ne sait plus très
bien ce que l'on sait c'est que la marie
gabrielle avait voguer deux jours déjà
sans le moindre rayon de soleil d'une
sans lui sous un ciel souder un horizon
bouché sous des nuées seabass que les
têtes des marci perdait 2 jours déjà que
la marie gabrielle dit c'est comme un
gigantesque oiseau blanc dans une
lumière de misère soudain la voix du
capitaine avait déchiré le silence ouaté
qui entourait le navire tout le monde
sur le pont paré a manoeuvré par et
capitaine marc à tribord tout chacun
regagnait sont postés là tu les bordées
de repos grimper on ne discutait pas les
ordres du capitaine visage taillé à
coups de serpe barbe de feu
on disait que le vieux avait le coeur
l'avait par toutes les tempêtes le gall
n'avait même pas eu le temps de gagner
la bande peau il se sentit catapulté en
avant dirait en arrière et finalement
entraîné dans un tourbillon d'une
puissance inimaginable
aveuglé par des paquets de mer qui lui
brûlait les yeux comme des petits dont
il roula sur lui-même encore et encore
son sang se glace à à la pensée que ça
allait peut être percuté quelques treuil
où l'un des mâts d'ailleurs était il
seulement encore sur le pot il était
temps étant trempé et bousculé de tous
côtés
qui sait s'il n'était pas passé par
dessus bord pour s'en aller poursuivre
solitaire sa route dans les flots
déchaînés
il lui semblait entendre déjà le
hurlement de la vague qui lui a porté la
voix des marins disparus en mer
soudain un craquement une douleur
fulgurante l'impression de sombrer dans
le néant à traverser pour pierre brullé
d'eau salée le gall a perçu la rambarde
de bois vernis de la goélette il comprit
que certaines venaient de heurter un
train
une lame gigantesque déferlait sur le
pont alors comme poussé par une force
incontrôlée il saisit un filin et cirque
rochât il était temps la vague balaya le
pont emportant tout sur son passage
cramponné au câble les mains en sang
dans un fracas de voile déchirée de
poulies et de chênes malmené il a tant
dit prête à un nouvel assaut il essaya
de protéger son visage contre la gifle
puissante qu'il le frapperait encore au
bout de quelques instants
il entrouvre y ses yeux brûlants là à
une routeur terrifiante surplombant le
pot de la marine gabriel se dressait un
navire géant un énorme trois mâts le
veilleur d'être avalés de apercevoir
trop tard s'agrippant de toute la force
de ses bras au malaise de la barre le
barreur n'avait pu dévier la marie
d'abriel atteint la barre manette archet
tournait comme folle
la goélette venait d'être abordés par ce
navire géant
déjà elle filait sur tribord gîtai comme
un immense oiseau blessé
les marins tout endurci qu'ils étaient
aux dangers de la mer pousser un cri à
leur poste
plusieurs d'entre eux gisait mort écrasé
par quelques verres bien à mettre les
baleinières à l'eau hurla le capitaine
bientôt six ans a certes où les hommes
du moins ce qu'ils étaient encore
vivants
les autres eux on les abandonnait
tandis que les chaloupes faisait route
vers le trois mâts le gall regardait son
beau navire il le vit toujours penché
sur tribord s'enfoncer dans la brume
ils sont allés rejoindre le pays d'où
les bateaux ne reviennent jamais les
yeux des vieux loups de mer ses
compagnons se voit l'air lui sert à la
mâchoire et ne dit rien après avoir
recueilli les naufragés le trois-mâts
repris sa route cap à l'est le capitaine
de la marine gabriel s'était retiré dans
le carré des officiers avec celui du
navire la brume était toujours aussi
dense et le gall ne parvenait pas à
distraire ses pensées de la marie
gabrielle soudain tout près de lui se
dessine à une forme comme surgies du
brouillard imprécises peu à peu ils
distinguent à la masse d'un voilier un
instant de ce cru victime de son
imagination ce qu'il voyait lui couper
le souffle
trois coups de cloche a retenti hier sur
le gaillard d'avant non il ne rêvait pas
trois coups
c'était bien un voilier à tribord une
étrave fonçait droit sur le voilier
silencieuse rapide
2 madre vers le ciel gris comme un défi
un frisson d'horreur parcouru le gall de
part en part
à quelques encablures la marque gabriel
sans bruit sans gîte toutes voiles
dehors taillait sa route dans le
brouillard
elle arrivait sur le trois mâts à droite
toute
l'homme de barman brassard ou au plus
vite
amenant les deux voiliers en route
parallèle avec elle fière allure la
marie gabrielle alors que chacun la
croyait au fond de l'océan
elle semblait défier le trois mâts qui
avait osé l'aborder quelques instants
les deux navires firent route côte à
côte puis le vaisseau fantôme s'enfonça
dans la brume une grande animation
éclate alors sur le pont du trois-mâts
un bateau fantôme balivernes lança marin
est il parti d'un grand éclat de rire
sait-on jamais fille d'un autre les yeux
perdus vers l'horizon bouché et
n'oubliez pas que la marie gabrielle
s'appelait autrefois l'intrépide dans un
vieux matelot à la barbe de braise
elle aura voulu se venger
on ne change pas comme ça le nom d'un
bateau et on n'en voit pas au fond de
l'océan
une goélette comme la marie gabrielle
sur la dunette les deux capitaines
discutait vivement et s'il s'agissait
d'un navire ressemblant à la marie
gabrielle lança le capitaine du trois
mâts à ces mots le visage de l'autre se
ferme a comme s'il venait de recevoir un
affront on l'entendît répondre d'une
voix cinglante impossible je connais mon
bateau alors quelqu'un sera resté à bord
hasarda encore le premier nom tous les
marins vivant sont la personne n'était
dû chacun savait bien que c'était là
marie gabrielle
qui avait surgi de la brume dans son
émoi le gall n'avait pas eu le temps de
lire le nom qui s'étalait sur la coque
du bateau mais il avait reconnu la
figure de proue
à l'avant il avait bien vu les deux
serpents entre là c'est au tour d'un
visage percée de larges yeux féroce mais
il en faut davantage pour effrayer les
rues de gars qui sillonnent l'océan
le trois-mâts déjà reprenait son cas sa
rencontre avec la marie gabrielle
rejoindrait ses légendes de bateaux
fantômes ou que l'on raconte dans les
tavernes de cherbourg ou de saint malo
devant un café noir arrosé de rome
soudain le cri du veilleur perça à
nouveau le silence tous les regards
scrutaient relais paix voile blanc qui
entourait le navire la marie gabrielle
déchire à la brume elle se rua sur le
trois mâts le frappa brisa net l'avant
de sa poupe et des éclats de bois
volèrent tu as plus de 10 pieds de haut
l'une de ces entrevues projeté sur le
pont le traverse à la vitesse d'un
boulet de canon sabbatique outre la
rambarde qu'elle transperça et finit sa
course dans une montagne des cubes en un
éclair
les deux hommes qui travaillaient dans
l'art ti monde disparurent dans les
vagues avec la voile et le mas déjà un
oiseau gigantesque ses deux ailes
blanches déployer plongeait sur les deux
marins qui se débattait dans les flots
le gall détourna son regard pour ne pas
voir son bec de graille et ses yeux
profonds comme des criques
un énorme fracas ce quoi une fois encore
le trois mâts qui n'étaient plus que
désolation
le mât d'artimon renvoyé par les lames
venait de crever la coque alors dans un
vacarme de toiles déchiré et de poulies
gré sentent le bateau fantôme s'évanouit
dans la brume le 3 mars se faisait lourd
l'eau montait dans ses cales il ne
tarderait certes pas accru et les hommes
se pressèrent dans les frêles
embarcations qui était mis à la mer il
était temps le navire se cabra comme un
cheval sauvage puis s'enfonce a
lentement dans les flux bientôt ne
restèrent plus à la surface que c'est ma
puis plus rien sans plus attendre les
chaloupes s'éloignèrent dans la brume
qui se faisait moins denses par le
soleil s'acharnait à percer la mer était
lisse
à l'horizon se profile est une ligne
bleuté la cote alors là marie gabrielle
sorti à son tour de la brume ont la vie
se détacher très net sur le ciel elle
s'enfonça lentement dans les flots puis
se couche à dressa sa poupe
et glissa dans l'océan elle était venue
s'assurer qu'elle était bien rangé
désormais elle pouvait couler en paix
bien du temps a passé depuis
si vous naviguez un jour au large de
cherbourg ou de saint malo mais vous
naviguerez sans doute jamais au large de
cherbourg de saint malo quelques jours
avant quelques jours après la grande
marée seuls les gens qui n'ont de google
choses de la mer s'y aventurent mais
ceux qui restent au port ou la
compteront cette légende
ils vous diront que la marie gabrielle
revient deux fois l'an et qu'elle envoie
par le font tous les vaisseaux qui
croisent sa route
certains à dix grandes comme une ville
d'autres petites comme une coque de noix
nul n'a jamais réussi à l'aborder les
intrépides qui s'y sont hasardés ont
grandement payer leur audace jamais ils
ne sont rentrés au port pour nous dire
qui bat label goélette
on raconte que les compagnons de le gall
ils y ont pris place pour l'éternité